back to leia inspired podcast powered by
icon plus so before we start i'm going
to give you a really quick news
announcement so
very excited to share with you that icon
2.0 has launched
this is a power boost to the icon
network for
next level decentralized finance and
enterprise adoption if you head over to
my twitter page there is a post of the
interview that i did with the founder
minkim
so you can check that out later so
that's really exciting for them but
without further ado we have a very
interesting guest today somebody who's
very infamous
for blocking a ridiculous amount of
people online so i'm quite a fan of that
and
i think we have a lot in common so
joining me is of course hotep
jesus how are you doing i'm doing great
great great thank you for having me yeah
it's great
to have you um i've been following you
for a while and i feel like we have
quite a lot in common in terms of
politics crypto
blocking people online um but before we
go into this i do want to just sort of
understand
because a lot of people don't know what
hotep is um i told some people that i
was having
hotep jesus on and they were like oh i
thought hotep was his first name
so yeah so that's the extent to which
people don't know about hotep so
hello yeah uh hotep has become sort of
like a title
uh like sir you know um
so uh hotep originally means peace or
satisfaction ancient metanator ancient
egypt
ancient egyptian language um it's become
a cultural thing for
uh what we call the conscious community
uh amongst the black community
has a lot of roots in the harlem new
york here on the east coast um
but uh i represent hotep nation
hotepnation.com if you go to
hotepnation.com hit the menu button and
navigate to the faq page you can
actually find out
uh everything that we stand for get a
lot of questions sorted out and answered
uh we uh uh
i think we have a lot of conservative
values so you'll see a lot of overlap
with us and
uh the conservative right and some
people will determine
and uh i think we just believe in um
independence we're not status by any
means
um and uh all about like economics right
like you know what do you produce and
then um how do you exchange that with
others and
uh what do you give in the world that's
going to
nourish life essentially so kind of like
the good old expression don't ask what
your country can do for you but ask what
you can do for your country i don't know
sort of like
personal responsibility a bit adding
value on your own without waiting
that's pretty it's pretty it's pretty
close yeah yeah i hate to say that
yeah that's pretty close i wouldn't say
identical but yeah you're right in that
lane right in that vein
yeah okay nice so this is interesting
because
conservative values um and 2020 has been
a crazy year so
a lot of things that i wanted to talk to
you today um about
well firstly mainly you know what's
going on this week with cuties
i know you've got some opinions on that
i want to chat to you about blm
um but let's start with cuties first so
this is interesting because actually i
posted um
why is netflix normanizing and
there's been a lot of um backlash for
that for some reason cuties has become
politicized right
for some reason pedophilia has become
politicized
um i know from a lot of the things that
i've read you're sort of
very much against what um you know
netflix put out in terms of duties but
why do you think with
it's being politicized why do you think
we're sort of seeing towards the left
we're seeing more people sort of saying
well actually
it's supposed to be for this it's
supposed to be for that
yeah i've heard that argument um i
couldn't stomach to sit down and watch
the film um even just from the clips
that i saw
uh i couldn't stomach the film to even
try and imagine so there you know it's
like
uh let's what i heard was they're trying
to
uh shed light on
the exploitation of children um
but in my interpretation they're doing
that by exploiting children
i i don't i don't get it like i think
there's another way
you know i don't know what kind of weird
[ __ ] they got going on in france
that would think this is cool way to get
across the message but i feel like uh
it's counterproductive it's
counterintuitive um
to what they purport their purposes or
their mission is with the creation of
this film
i think it's disgusting and um
you know as as a quote unquote hotep we
have studied the work of uh
dr francis kress wilson in her book the
isis papers
uh she predicted this you know she
predicted the normalization of the uh
lgbtq lifestyle which i have no problem
with
um and uh i believe they deserve
the right to marry and uh the right to
uh associate etc um
and to practice that lifestyle uh but uh
my ancestors like uh dr francis crush
wilson
has warned us that the next stage of
this
uh would be uh pedophilia
and uh yeah go on sorry no no go ahead
yeah i mean i think it's really
interesting because when we talk about
lgbtq
or whatever you know we sort of say yeah
okay that you know
we agree they deserve the right to
marriage and so on and so on equal
rights and everything but
why would pedophilia sort of be thrown
into that bracket
why is that the next step for you
yeah well i couldn't answer that
question directly
um because people might try to truncate
the clip
and misconstrue my words but instead
what i'll do is
i'll tell you a historical uh reference
and uh if we flash back to greece uh in
greece
um homosexuality was uh normalized as
long as it was between uh
an older man and a young boy but if it
was uh
two men uh dylan
two grown men didlin then it was
considered homosexuality but otherwise
it was considered
grooming so to speak i didn't know this
yeah uh i believe uh plato uh
has um or socrates has recorded
some of these acts uh to which they um i
believe the author did not agree with
um and that's all i'm going to say
about that anybody can infer from that
what they will
yeah i mean it kind of reminds me of um
i mean i know you said you're sort of
not based on the west coast
of the states but it sort of reminds me
of like laws that we've seen come out
recently in california
um sort of um i i can't really i don't
really know it fully follow it but it's
something like uh
the laws have been reduced if it's um
the same sex and it's between
someone underage and over overage or
whatever it is
[Music]
okay cool so you see the alignment
yes i guess i'm seeing some alignments
absolutely um
but i mean it's interesting i've had
people sort of i totally agree with you
when you say you know
if you want to raise the issue about
exploitation there's no need to exploit
children
in doing so i was talking to somebody
actually earlier today
about this um i don't know how much you
know about the uk or grooming gangs or
whatever but
grooming gangs is a big issue in the uk
um grooming gangs what's that
yeah okay cool so you know about
grooming gang so basically um
so just the facts of the matter is we
have a big issue so there's um
it's the pakistani community not
obviously all of them there's a fraction
um it's a pocket of society um and they
prey on white
poor um english girls um between the
ages
of i don't know like 11 to 15 or
whatever and they groom them
rape them and so on so that's been a big
issue in the uk
now netflix and the bbc actually did a
documentary on this
and they were able to highlight the
issue without
wetting the appetite of the groomers
themselves
essentially that's what i'm getting at
so i i to some extent i appreciate okay
fine so you wanted to shed light on an
issue
but it's very odd that they had to
exploit children doing so
yeah yeah such a terrible decision to
make i don't understand
uh what the people who signed off on
this were thinking
yeah i mean either i mean you keep here
i mean i keep hearing things like
hollywood is
full of all sorts so hollywood
um okay cool so another really
interesting topic this week
is kanye west so he is kanye's doing
kanye he's
uh going on the those rampage and i
think connie's an interesting one
because he
often speaks his mind and sort of gets
um trampled on for doing so right he
gets a lot of hate for speaking his mind
um i kind of wanted to get your opinion
and know where you're at with that
um you know he's a trump supporter he's
not a trump supporter
um you know he's very anti this whole
victim mentality he's spoken a lot about
slavery and how people are enslaving
themselves
just want to know where are you at with
that do you have any sympathy for kanye
or
are you uh
so um what good is it to have a free
body if you don't have a free mind
and that's where we are right now that's
the crossroads
of the big political conversation is
um are you free to think as you wish
uh if you're not free to think as you
wish you you definitely can't speak
as you wish um so where we've we've
uh reached a point where
uh people are committing thought crimes
and uh kanye is committing speech crimes
uh according to people who don't believe
that we should have free minds
um so again i would like to
reiterate that we are in a position
where we're faced with
mental slavery and that's what kanye is
is always alluding to is the fact that
people aren't free you know you make a
certain decision to say hey look i'm not
supporting a democratic candidate and
all of a sudden
it's oh you're trying to throw the
election right like so i don't have the
freedom of choice you're saying if i
don't make this decision then
i must be compromised or something must
be wrong with me
right and that's the uh exact freedom
that they're trying to take away from us
right now and
uh joe biden said uh if you don't vote
for me you ain't black
hey um that's crazy
and as as as as
as as uh
uh inappropriate i should say as
inappropriate as that
comment was from him it is actually
quite also accurate
if we go by the numbers yeah by the
numbers
if we went by the math that would be
true
so in some ways i looked at him and i
said you scumbag for saying that but
then
thinking objectively i'm like he's just
cocky and he knows exactly
um the type of control the democratic
party has
over the black nation black people in
america
and i think that is uh
the the manifestation of the mental
slavery the fact that
you can basically fear monger people
under saying
vote or die right like so
um kanye's been going crazy on twitter
recently uh as people would say going
crazy
i would say i think it's crazy and now i
think he's uh
he's doing what you do when you get
power right yeah
he got [ __ ] you money and when you get
that type of money
um you start acting like it um and
and you start exposing some of the
things that are wrong with the world you
know like he was talking about the
contracts that
record labels have i think it's a it's
it's it's time to
you know i'm not a status i don't
believe that the government should get
involved in these contracts but i
believe that we the people
um or industry who gets involved with
these uh
record labels have a power to negotiate
better contracts we uh have negotiated
better contracts in the world of vcs the
world of
startups right and those contracts
have become quite fair to both the
investor
and the uh startup uh
those contracts do not look anywhere
near the same as far as our label is
concerned
and um the relationship is actually
quite similar
where the artist is actually the startup
but
has no equity in the thing that he
started up
it doesn't even work like that in the
startup world usually you start off with
equity and people buy pieces of equity
whereas when you enter into a deal with
these uh record labels
they start off with the equity and they
tell you what you're gonna get from
your product or your idea your startup
so i think it's a fight that needs to be
had and i love that he's having it
um sam cook had that um fight they
murdered him
um a lot of uh michael jackson had that
fight with sony
are you on the mj one yeah and
we know what happened with uh the late
great mj
um so and and kanye brought that up as
well
but uh i've been following kanye i've
never
uh deviated from uh
being a a supporter of his
you know an advocate of his message i
love kanye
i love what he does and um i think you
just keep doing it
yeah i think that's cool i think you
know a lot of interesting things there
um let's go back to the biden comment
right so
so you're not black if you don't vote
democrat
i think biden is playing the ultimate
game of identity politics
and you're right like he totally knows
that he's doing it
and i think it's very interesting to
sort of hear you know the democratic
party being the party which will say
we will be your saviors um meanwhile
sort of
not allowing you to have your own
independent thought um which in itself
is to be honest the most racist thing
i've ever come across in my life
yeah yeah i i was uh thinking today
about this new premise called uh
inclusivity is actually
masquerading as exclusive no exclusivity
is masquerading as
inclusivity right yeah exactly if you
don't do it the right way
yeah it's like you know the left
proposed to be
inclusive right and it's like inclusive
of what
your selection of who you decide to
include is actually
exclusive because you exclude
an entire school of thought
because you don't agree with it so
inclusivity is actually
exclusivity uh and it's rather
disgusting
that they would uh try to play mind
games with us like this
yeah i know i'm totally with you and i
think it kind of leads me on to the next
thing i want to
sort of talk about which is victim
mentality and you talk about you know
hoteps being awake
um you know uh i think that's the word
you used or you know kanye west is awake
um people sort of you know when the
whole
the riots the blm rights were going on
there was a lot of pain
on the streets um and rightly so
you know rightly so i can sort of i can
feel the pain all the way from the uk
but my question to you then is why
aren't people why why are people sort of
i guess like you put it like kanye put
it so i'm still enslaved in their minds
and unable to sort of wake up um you
know you talk about people having to
um lift themselves up from their own
bootstraps essentially
yeah well the uh program was installed
in
the the parents and the grandparents
so mentality yeah
i mean human mind is a computer
and we very much have an operating
system that's given to us um
from from the first time we start
interacting with people we start getting
these downloads from our mother our
father and then
uh the greater environment and um
people aren't selected with what they
allow their mind to download
and that's really what this is about
being selective in your downloads
um people
are downloading a lot of propaganda
people are downloading a lot of
misinformation uh
the um grade schools
are the first places of propaganda
the liberal universities are the you
know uh
the second level of propaganda as far as
education is concerned
um thank you very much baby
what are you drinking uh a bit of coffee
yeah um so yeah you know um
so so so you have that first problem
which is
the parents are programmed right i got
lucky
you know when i landed on this rock um
my father was quote unquote woke right
he was awake like real work or like
like real work
yeah you know red peeled out so
um i had those seeds planted early
you know so and this kind of segues into
the pull yourself up by the bootstraps
conversation right because
there's two sides of this coin there's
one is you can pull yourself
up by the bootstraps and the other one
is uh you don't even know how to find
your bootstraps
no that is all right again
um and and i think that's that's the the
bigger problem
um we have to show people how to find
their bootstraps
we gotta you know yes they can pull them
up
but sometimes we gotta turn the light on
for them so they can find their boots
and get them on you know and
um so for example i was on a crypto pod
a couple weeks ago with shinobi
uh maybe a month ago shinobi and i was
talking about
the advantage of being in proximity to
information has a lot to do with
how fast you excel in this world if
you're in a hub
which is filled with a lot of
information and high net worth and
networking individuals
you're going to rise the ranks of the
classes a lot faster than somebody who
was
uh born in a jungle
in the middle of south america right
yeah
right the only thing they know is uh
probably survival right
and then you can take that up next level
you got the kid in arkansas who
you know uh lives on a farm and he got
chickens and they tend to their own
you know he'd be lucky if he has wi-fi
right
now imagine somebody who you know their
the the the highest level of experience
they have with technology is wi-fi
right like how are you going to get them
involved in crypto
how are you even going to start to
explain krypto to them and you know like
but somebody who is born in new york
city
who where some of these digital
ideas are abundant in just part of your
normal everyday life just especially
like uh you know
taking uh public transportation how some
of these things have transactions
happening digitally
it's just quite different than other
rural areas
so yeah you can pull yourself by the
bootstraps but sometimes we need people
to show other people the way like hey
you know like i like i spoke to uh i've
consulted quite a few people and i'm
like where do you live that's like
sometimes one of the first questions i
asked where do you live it's like all
right well if you want to do that career
you need to get the hell up out of where
you are
[Applause]
you know uh you might need to move to uh
cali or one of the major markets like uh
texas
florida right if you want to excel and
get
you know um more careers otherwise you
need somebody to show you how to do it
online
right and that's why i think youtube is
so great like you have your platform
wendy's platform where people can tap
in and get access to information i think
that's what makes this generation so
different is that people can just tap in
and it's like they're getting all the
downloads from new york city by being in
new york city but they're still in
arkansas getting through their wi-fi i
think these things are great
um but sometimes still you need that
person to
retweet that onto your timeline right
yeah or run into it on instagram because
you might be
let's say you're an instagram that
algorithm might just have you in a
bubble
and you'll never yeah right
so you get stuck in these bubbles and
and twitter is like that too where you
can get stuck in a bubble you only see
a certain type of message certain type
of viewpoint certain types of
information
and and and um so that that that's like
the second half the problem can people
pull themselves up by the bullet strap
well that's the first half of the
problem now
can people pull this also out of
bootstrap it's the second half of the
problem it's like well once they have
access to information now it's just
do you have the ambition and to want to
go and desire to go and do it and
achieve what you want to achieve right
and i think that um black people are in
no position
uh to complain uh about our position in
society because there are enough of us
who um are willing to help and and
provide i give a wealth of information
out
um to people when i get my access to
people uh
and you know carl civil right you know
there's a lot of dope dudes like it's a
lot of people
crypto blood you know a lot of people
who give great information
um and they're sort of pushed to the
back in favor of
somebody who's going to complain about
white people
right and and and kind of keep the
political circus
uh going and um
yeah yeah that stuff that stuff is uh
sensationalized and
you know yeah no i i think you make some
interesting points there
um especially about people being
programmed and you sort of saying well
you're privileged because you know your
father was woke he sort of instilled an
idea
into you that you know you can do what
you want despite the color of your skin
despite what people may tell you
yeah um but in terms of sort of
showing like you said showing people
where their bootstraps are or telling
people that you do have bootstraps
okay so we have people online like you
said um that they can follow like
yourself you have a lot of successful
black people which you know can sort of
show them that things are possible um
but do you think we need more because
when i was
you know i'm here in the uk i saw what
was going on during
the whole black lives matter thing you
know the riots on the streets and
despite the negativity that sort of
comes with black lives matter that aside
there were people on the streets that
were in pain and
they are unable to sort of see beyond
their circumstances
so at what point can we sort of instill
something here do you think that we need
um i don't know do you think we need
like a martin luther king kind of energy
going on there like somebody that's
going to come up and sort of
speak directly to black people and sort
of say like you know you can
is it the education system that needs to
be changed um
because honestly in my opinion um no
president is gonna do this no black
president you know you had obama
you know obama i don't really think
instilled much faith in the black
community honestly um
i know you've got michelle obama which
is supposed to be this
icon for black young girls but there's
still an
issue there so
how do you wake them up you don't
you don't you don't you don't um what we
have to understand is that
um there is always going to be the dumb
deaf and blind see i come from the
school of authority the five percenters
you know and five percent is gonna be uh
five percent only five percent of nature
is going to be um
righteous with their wokeness then you
have the other 15
you know who are are are awake but they
play the game like they grift and
they're the politicians and they know
how this whole world
like joe biden like i'm straight up
believing joe biden knows
he knows what he's doing he knows how
the democratic party are not helping
your you know your side like it's not
helping exactly
but he's enriching himself right and his
people and his family
right so then you have you know so again
we come down to this 80 20 rule
right and it's like 20 percent of people
influence
the other 80 percent right so 80 are
dumb deaf and blind
now this thing is going to cross racial
barriers
no matter where you go whatever nation
you have eighty percent of people are
gonna
fall lockstep with uh the propaganda
uh and of course this is gonna vary
based upon nations right
um and it's gonna vary especially to
with homogeneous places like china
it's homogenous and there's a lot of
chinese pride that the chinese people
have and
their heritage and they believe in
working together so it's going to be a
little bit different than
a place like america which is supposed
to be so diverse in the melting pot
but 80 of people gonna be dumb deaf and
blind and that crosses racial barriers
i run into white people all the time i'm
just like oh you're just dumb deaf and
blind
it's nothing i can do to really help you
um
you know so what did the 5 nation do
well what we do is
the people who um can see those those
who have eyes who can see ears who can
hear
then we lend them a voice and we show
them the way
we don't you can't force people yeah we
don't concern ourselves
with people who uh we have to force to
conform it's actually a sin
to force people to conform to your ideas
like if you want to go out in the street
and you want to protest and you want to
you know
wear pronouns who am i to tell you what
you're doing is wrong
knock your [ __ ] self out i don't give
a [ __ ] right just leave me alone
right so yeah what i believe in is just
making
a message that just so powerful that it
drowns out
these other messages and i think that's
what's more powerful
you know what is your message what do
you what did you build
because it's not that you know black
people need to just need an
alternative way of life they need an
alternative view they need somebody
brave enough that's going to step up and
just show them
another way and when they see another
way and you see that other way is
working
and they see the lambos and the ferraris
yeah they'll fall in line you know
you see the protests stop and say you
know what i kind of you know
i think i want to be rich i think i want
to be one of the rich right and they
start
seeing that it's okay to have luxury
it's okay to
to live a good life uh socials do a good
job of making people hate
being rich or hate the rich and um
they like to pray on the week um so but
you know let's talk about black lives
matter people on the street you know
i think these people uh have a
legitimate right right
like there is a police problem in
america
i'm not gonna doubt that there is a
racial problem
in america um
and i know they feel pain i know they
feel pain every time one of these
incidents
are blown up on the media yeah
right what they don't realize is that
their emotions are being tugged and
pulled
you see there are a million problems
with the world there are a million
problems with the black community we can
just start with
the top three top three are uh
diabetes high blood pressure and heart
disease
i wasn't expecting those top three okay
i wasn't
expecting that but yeah those are the
top three
killers of the black community and
outside of abortion
right nobody talks about that nobody's
marching in the streets for that right a
big mac gonna kill your ass before a cop
do
right these are the facts
so who is telling you
or who is selecting the problems that
you
decide to fight here
i can't say who okay for my safety
and yours we'll cut off that which after
yeah so you know
and it doesn't even matter who because
we're going to drown their message out
we're going to make them irrelevant
you know um but uh
who who says police brutality
is the problem because i don't think
police brutality
is the first and foremost problem i
believe that there are problems
that you can solve that will solve that
uh just by being a tree being see
police brutality is is a branch of a
bigger problem
the biggest symptom of the cause yes
yes yes so the bigger problem
i would say is um
inefficient economics
the economics within the black community
is broken therefore
um they are left begging begging
democrats
for health care begging democrats
for minimum wage or welfare or whatever
it is
when really these problems like jason
whitlock was on my show last week and he
said uh
nfl has produced more black male
millionaires than anything else
i had to think about i'm like he's
absolutely right so where is this wealth
going when
i believe over 60 percent of these
athletes are gonna lose that wolf by the
time they retire or a few years after
they retire right so where is this
wealth going right so it's not like we
don't have the wealth
we see rappers in the strip club and
they're throwing they might throw a
million dollars in a cert club in one
night i've seen a couple of times happen
so
it's not like the wealth isn't there
right
it's just a matter of what we do with it
once we get it
uh lauren hill had this line she said
it's not about what you cop
it's about what you keep so you can get
money the question is can you keep it
right and then can you multiply it um
there there's not enough diversity in in
small business amongst
the black community i think that's a
huge problem
um we sent we tend to center around the
same types of businesses if you take the
top 10
um black um business
directories right they like to make
these directories oh
check out all the black businesses all
the black businesses and they got the
same
fashion hair entertainment right
same thing over and over again and even
if
these are lucrative industries do not
give me wrongs a lot of money and beauty
it's a multi-billion dollar industry in
beauty
right the problem is we start competing
with each other
instead of trying to find complementary
solutions within the business
right so right now like the eyelash
thing is popping so everybody's getting
into
aesthetics right and everybody's doing
aesthetics so it's like are we thinking
about the peripheral
ideas that can happen to
uh facilitate some of these businesses
right and i don't think
we're taking a look at that i don't
think we're taking a good strong look at
how we optimize some of these industries
and and become middlemen
you know we don't control none of the
supply chain which is a whole nother
story
but uh i'm gonna jump in um so a couple
of things that
really very much about sort of
understanding really it's just business
isn't it whether it be financial
financial literacy or um
you know learning how to sort of
diversify within
the sort of things that the black
community offers when it comes to
business
but my question is then um the black
community right
to use this kind of term you know
america is huge
it's huge you know there's all i don't
know how many black people there are in
america i can give you a stat maybe you
know
40. it's very much how many
yeah yeah okay cool so 40 million right
so it's very
the way i look at it it's very difficult
to sort of do you really think it's that
much of a community
do you really think that 40 million
people
are that much you know black people in
the south the same as black people on
the east coast on the west coast like is
there really this kind of
community whereby you know there's um a
conversation that can happen
amongst 40 million people which is guys
you know let's diversify our business
let's do
do you know do you know what i mean or
do you think or do you think the problem
should be tackled more at like a
national level put race aside
and sort of say you know people you know
let's teach financial literacy in school
so that whites
and black people sort of understand
financial literacy you know when you
make your million dollars know
how to invest that how to how to
multiply it um
so once again once again we've fallen
back upon
depending on the state yeah
never do that that's true but i'm just
kind of like
thinking we know we don't when as as
black people we do not want to do
anything nationally we don't want to do
anything in cooperation with other races
right um outside of economics
i think when we're talking about
building the next generation that is the
responsibility
of the elders of each race or ethnicity
right so grandma god teach mama mama
gotta teach daughter right
so economics do you think the kids that
excel in finance learn economics in
school do you think it's
in the family oh absolutely not in
school because they don't teach it so it
is in the family
well that's where the responsibility
relies it relies on this
but like what you know what if you're
just born into that situation where you
can't get it from the family but then
like it's like we said you'd get it
online and you'd look
right and that's why i said that's the
big problem having access to information
like i said we got option games right
option gang's carl civil right right
he's showing people how to trade options
one of the dopest guys out here doing it
black guy
why isn't he on the cover of black
enterprise magazine
why that's that's my point you see what
i'm saying it's because he doesn't think
like the rest because
he's because they've seen him in a maga
hat
it's a problem but this is a black dude
from new york that is as real as you can
get
but still make a proper difference yes
and understands wall street he's
understands the streets and he
understands wall street
right so a little too real for them to
to to push to the forefront and that's
the problem these people
aren't getting the looks that they
should and the information is not
getting out there but you said
can 40 i think it's 47 million now the
black community is
yeah so i think let's look at social
media
do you realize like how much
uh black people have in common and is
shown on social media like some of these
trending topics
that come from black twitter like black
twitter could
easily uh on some days have like the top
three trending topics just based upon
celebrity gossip
black twitter or black american twitter
just out of interest
uh i would say black american twitter
which is black black twitter
okay yeah uh so you know some of this
celebrity gossip
um can last you know conversations like
what was the conversation that just
happened
uh recently i saw number one trending
topic last night
um who was oh kanye right well kanye's
he kind of uh he took over twitter he
penetrated all sorts of twitter
not just black twitter yeah um
who was the other guy i mean it happens
all the time right like
uh odell beckham some little groupie
said something about odell beckham and
and and and black twitter had a ball
with it like there's a lot of different
verses for example the verses you ever
see the verses
so verses they have like uh
quote-unquote battles so one of the
battles they had was uh
uh snoop dogg versus dmx and they come
and they play like their top 20
hits or whatever uh they sell like 20
records and they play them you never
seen this before
i've never seen it maybe i have maybe i
have i don't know i don't know you show
me after leave me a link
this is huge in the black community like
everybody who's black knows about this
right
and that's why i said like you might be
in a bubble like you're in london you're
in a bubble
you wouldn't you don't know anything
about this stuff right and this is what
happens with social media
something can trend number one and you
wouldn't even know about it right
because you're in london and we're
talking about american culture
then you have uh the last one they did
was patti labelle
gladys knight right like like that's a
classic
brandy verse monica was it was another
right do you familiar with brandy and
monica it might be a little too old i
know of this
but like not obviously not as much as
you are okay yeah
you have to show me after i we need to
exchange some links
so yeah so you know they'll get a
million views on some of these things on
on instagram live a million view a live
viewers a million live viewers they're
over indexing what people would do on tv
this is black culture so when you have
that many
eyes that go to one single place
think about what advertisers would like
to do
knowing they have a million live eyes
focused in on one spot
that is also an opportunity for you to
plug your own propaganda to reprogram
your people
so yes there's a community and they meet
at these places in these venues these
digital venues
so there's a lot of opportunity to
disseminate the correct information
i just don't think we capture the
opportunities
but it is definitely it is definitely a
a community a lot of people
especially white people like to say oh
there is no such thing as a black
community well to white people it might
not be
but you know when people say is there a
difference between
a black man from chicago a black man
saint louis new york miami and houston
hell yeah it is how yeah it is without a
question there's definitely differences
it's dialects
dress language all of that it's all
different
you know um and in new york you whack
and
in atlanta you green as [ __ ] they mean
the same thing
right so there are differences
but there are points of unification
within the culture uh that we all meet
up on
a lot of them might be um url rap
battles
you know but there are places of
unification and there are a lot of
unsaid gestures that we understand about
each other for example
when we typed in child like
child please are you familiar with that
talk
no i'm not no okay so so so you know
when you say child please
that's very much southern twenty i mean
well we spell it like c-h-i-l-e
right oh okay but it's we're basically
saying cha yold
please right we'll say child please now
it's spelled c-h-i-l-e and some girl
grabs
the tick-tock and goes to tick-tock and
she says chili please
so she doesn't even she's reading it but
she doesn't know where the spelling
comes so as i said we have like our own
community that people have no idea
what's happening inside this bubble
so a lot of things can compos can be
possible
um we just have to give people access to
that information and use these uh
digital venues for that yeah that's
interesting to hear you know that there
is a place
you know digitally which can bring
everybody together and it can be a good
place to sort of target and sort of
wake people up if that's you know what
you want to do um
but i am conscious of time so i also
kind of wanted to chat to you
um about crypto you mentioned lambos
earlier
um so i don't fully know we chatted a
little bit earlier but you obviously
you're you've co-founded you're a
partner of something to do a crypto tell
us
coinbitsapp.com automatic bitcoin
investing you ain't got to think about
it cause a dollar per transaction
uh wonderful app uh our users are
are are very happy um especially
because we go off the dollar cost
averaging uh investment strategy which
is the smartest investment strategy you
can do across all asset classes
um so yeah it's great things happening
over there shout out to maher yusuf my
partners who started the company and
brought me on later on as
sort of a branding and marketing art and
uh we're just uh slowly building that
company up and um
looking to do some great things in the
future with it yeah so
firstly how did you get into crypto
and what are your thoughts on bitcoin um
i mean
being in tech you kind of have to know
about crypto right
yeah so um you know i was in the mobile
app space for years
and um keeping an eye on crypto so i
made a little bit of money when they had
the boom in
2017 you know and you know i'm a
traditional investor so i knew
i knew to get out at the top and so
everybody else that got hit i'm just
like oh sorry for you i'm a trainer
traditional investor you know what
you're doing yeah
but when i saw the crash i understood
something uh that was very important and
i said uh
you know who who didn't lose money and
uh
that answer was the exchanges
yeah of course and uh in my head i said
you know i'd love to be in exchange
so um that actually manifested and here
i am working with my hearing yousef
on that uh bitcoin and trying to turn it
into an exchange
some legal communist issues involved but
uh
just some monetary hurdles will have to
get over yeah i hear you um
but in terms of you know like bitcoin
being the next financial revolution
i mean what are your thoughts i mean i
think it was i think it was jason
williams that tweeted like
the bitcoin is going to replace the
dollar or it's going to be
you know america's main currency is this
even likely given that it can't scale
right now although people are building
on top of it you've got the lightning
network which hopefully sort of you know
fixes this uh a lot of people have
um all right for example
uh the investor who comes in and invests
at
the seed round right is very happy when
the company has a series a round because
he's made money as long as the valuation
has increased in the company
uh and so on so forth so it it i hate to
call it a pyramid scheme but it
oh damn but uh these people
are are pushing in my opinion um a
pyramid scheme
you know um well you think bitcoin is a
uh no i think that's what it is to these
people that push that type of rhetoric
like bitcoin is going to do all these
great things
right i don't see bitcoin doing all
these great things
um uh
uh bitcoin is very interesting the
technology is very interesting i think
blockchain is a great piece of
technology
i think there are many coins out there
that solve many different types of
problems
um i love that it diversified money
that's what i love about crypto it
diversified money and i think that's
what money needed it needed to be
diversified people needed other options
so i love crypto i don't
want to just pile on the bitcoin
maximalist thing and say bitcoin bitcoin
bitcoin i think that's the wrong thing
to do
um i think uh bitcoin is not a good uh
means of exchange but i do enjoy it as a
store of value and i think it can be
used
as a great store of value and um i think
that's what it should be used for
um at its current state obviously
yeah like there's the goat correct i
don't see it being used as money
as we know it just physically can't work
the technology don't work
it don't work to do transactions i'm not
waiting 30 minutes to buy a cup of
coffee it's just not gonna happen
and lightning network is just uh not the
solution
um i think lightning
network can work in small communities
like small
trusted communities right um so
i think there is some viability for that
um but yeah you know these
you know these these these pumps of hope
i just look at it this is more
propaganda marketing people
trying to find ways to boost their their
ego trying to boost their brand
using bitcoin to boost their brand
making all these
gestures of grandeur uh i don't get
involved in it much i don't respond to
it much
it's just embellishment and i don't know
i find it childish i think it we should
be honest and tell people exactly what
it is
uh 60 of the bitcoin mining power comes
out of china
i don't call bitcoin bitcoin i call it
china coin
uh interesting yeah that's what i call
it yeah
yeah and bitcoin can't be for the people
because the people cannot afford the
bitcoin mining machines
it's yeah i mean it's an interesting one
because there is that kind of bitcoin
maximalist rhetoric in the space
and um i mean a lot of people have sort
of said that
that kind of claim that the mining pools
are centralized in china have been
debunked
um which i think there needs to be more
of an explanation on that i don't think
it's fully
been debunked in layman's terms um so i
think there needs to be more explanation
on that but
um yeah i mean it's an inch it's an
interesting one um
i think i hear you when people talk
about um you know crazy claims
and i don't think it's going to replace
the dollar um i think something will
replace something will replace the
dollar
i don't know whether it's going to be
bitcoin um
but i definitely think that we are
moving forward in terms of there being
crypto cryptocurrencies being a
the global currency right so i think
there will be a form of digital money
which will replace
um the dollar but i also think that
we're gonna see a sort of
push and pull between whether so i don't
know how much i don't know how much
of crypto you know or whatever but you
know you have um
cbdc's right so these are like central
banks
digital currencies so i think we're
going to have a push and pull between
that
and the people's cryptocurrency right
which is decentralized
and it's for the people so i think we're
moving forward in that way
but i don't know who's going to win it's
going to be a target
you don't think somebody has to win
surely there'll be a war between the
people and the government's coin
no no they will both coexist at the same
exact time
interesting like positive and negative
in an atom they will balance each other
out
that's what will happen there is no war
between the two coins one has one
purpose and the other one serves another
completely different purpose
one is uh a machine to levy debt
upon people and the other one is a
machine
to free debt from people so both will
exist
oh it's interesting i i just i can't see
them coexisting when people find the
power of crypto
even when you look at things like
privacy coins right like okay i'll show
you an example
yeah go for it okay beautiful new house
you want to go into need to put a down
payment
we only accept usd coin what are you
going to do about that
i'm gonna have to have usd coin boom
done
they're going to control at the higher
levels of banking if you go
to amazon and amazon does not accept
your little rinky dinky coin
what are you gonna do are you just gonna
stop shopping at amazon
you do you really think you're going no
of course not but that's what i'm saying
but that's what i'm saying so i'm saying
so then the government's coin wins
no it doesn't look like because i think
i think i think what we have now
now it's sort of co-existing-ish
but only within a community right with
only within crypto i can't exactly go
spend my crypto anywhere or
pay my rent in crypto i can't do that
but what does win
mean when you say win win what how did
is it like becoming that win as in like
becoming that global currency
you know there will be a global currency
it would not be the one for the people
though it will be the central bank
well then okay then that's what i'm
saying so then i would say people
are are way too [ __ ] uh
to uh to fight the central bankers
so the central banks are going to win we
can't even win the
the pedo war we can't even tell the left
that pedophilia is bad do you think
we're going to win
uh a coin war do you really think we're
going to coin
that's what i'm saying though that
that's what i'm saying so i think one
will win i'm not necessarily saying that
crypto will be outlawed
i think privacy coins are different um
but i'm not saying crypto be outlawed
i'm just saying i think one would win
when it comes to being mass adopted i
think
that the global
establishment cryptocoin will win
will be a win for the independent coin
you see they need each other
if the if the global you know corrupt
coin does not exist you don't have a
purpose
for the other coins i hear you i hate it
they need each other they they they
really the even the crypto coins they
use
when you say bitcoin oh what is the
talking point it's not how great bitcoin
is it's
always in juxtaposition to the dollar
why can't you talk about bitcoin and
remove dot the dollar from the
conversation completely
why can't you do that that's cool i like
that
that's cool it's always the position to
each other
so which tells me oh bitcoin must not be
that great if they can't
just like the the the the right the
conservatives
only thing they can do is put things in
juxtaposition to the left
what is your ideology what do you stand
for how is it great how is it going to
benefit people don't tell me about the
left tell me what you have to offer
same thing with bitcoin don't tell me
about the dollar tell me what you have
to offer
you have nothing to offer okay then
leave me the hell alone
i can stack coins i can stack my
satoshi's and i can invest in it like
gold and i can do well for myself
but don't sell me these dreams of
grandeur don't sell me these dreams of a
global coin because you can't even
transact a cup of coffee
i don't want to hear about it i just
don't want to hear about it
right no okay so but but
they don't need to win you see the
bigger the global
crypt uh uh a corrupt coin gets the
bigger the
let's call it the black market gets okay
it's they go they're gonna get it they
they they complement each other in a
really perverse kind of
weird way i hear you i hear you i think
that's really interesting um but it's
funny you know
you mentioned the right sort of talk
about what they can do
um in relation to the left but actually
what i'll say on like a leaving notes we
are approaching an hour
um for me joe biden is a really
interesting candidate because i don't
even know what he stands for other than
he's not trump
like right right right that's his
argument right his argument is i'm not
trump
it's like that's not an argument right
you have nothing to offer me
right yeah other than high taxes yeah
and that's and that's the problem with
the 80 the dumb deaf and blind
are you allowing these juxtaposition
arguments to happen
or you asking these people no what do
you really stand for
i hear you i hear you this has been a
really interesting conversation
and it's been kind of fun because it's
kind of circled yeah
background yeah i want to thank you so
much
um it's been really great chatting to
you um i want to thank everyone that
tuned in
um i think there's been a lot of
interesting comments i haven't really
spoken about that but
uh yeah this is an interesting comment
so thank you so much i'm gonna end the
broadcast
and uh we'll see you all next week
thursday 12 est bye